and then you can open it and there's
vagina stuff there
my experience with vaginas has been
mostly just sex with them so I'm gay
which means my experience with female
anatomy comes exclusively from my one
year of high school anatomy in high
school I was very scared of vaginas I
think I could get the general shape but
I don't know how well I know the
intricate vagina stuff I don't really
know what like a proper vagina looks
like much less how to draw one isn't a
vagina just like an inverted penis or
something I've never said vagina so many
times in my life all right let's try and
draw this what is this another shape
like this like something up here maybe
what don't [ __ ] some things should go
here this feels too blank for any type
of genital I think the vaginal opening
is in the middle that is where the penis
goes for sex like this never I don't
think it's ever that big if it is that's
that's cool too labia majora labia
majora
labia majora that's this a clitoris
right that's these these inner lips it's
that right the time that's on the inside
that's the line I drew here the labia
minora there's a labia minora
what is this hanukkah the clitoris is
this this little man in the canoe up
there that's this one at the top right
wouldn't that be the vagina I think
that's at the bottom what are you gonna
say like a little hole right here
mom's pubis I don't know if I want to
talk about my mom's cube is right now
okay that's all right
right there I think the anus is above
that's the anus I got some stuff whoa
that's like a that's a graphic picture
right there yes I think the holes are
misplaced oh my god
there's two flaps the scales a little
off this is a huge vagina
it's like you got to open it up like
like a lettuce I feel like people are
gonna say guys have no idea what a
vagina actually looks like this has
definitely changed the way that they're
looking for giant is now I'm like I'm
like kind of in awe
there's babies there's orgasms vaginas
do a lot we should respect that
good job vagina like good on you you
look cool you're intricate organ and
it's impressive vaginas are complicated
but they're important that's how we are
all here so I guess it makes sense to
like learn more about them vagina vagina
vagina its vagina man okay we've gotten
past it I can say vagina now I'm at it's
out of my system vagina but vagina
vagina vagina vagina